des conditions climatiques anglo saxon
pour ce chef de division honneur union
rugby centre 60,18 recevait à montigny
le bretonneux le club de vitry à
l'occasion de la 13e journée sous la
pluie les yvelinois subissent dans un
premier temps les assauts des joueurs du
val de marne avant de se reprendre puis
de marquer cet essai c'est à 8 à la
pause c'est vrai qu'au début on va faut
le tendre quand même de travailler un
peu hâlé défense l équipe en face mais
après en mettant en place notre jeu mais
on a su les mettre en difficulté et puis
voilà au fur et à mesure transfert notre
match en pâtit au retour des vestiaires
lui verser 60 18 dérouler les joueurs du
94 sous l'eau et de marque rond plus le
score à la fin de la rencontre est sans
appel 29 à 8 pour les saint quentinois
au score est assez large mais faut pas
oublier que là on avait trois minutes à
rentrer dans le match on a vécu mais les
fautes on a manqué de rigueur mais a su
se reprendre les consignes ont été
appliquées aux habitants pour ça on
aurait pu davantage qu'aux et puisqu'on
passe offre presque 20 minutes dans
leurs vingt-deux donc on a du travail
mais c'est ça qui est bien au classement
les yvelinois se retrouve désormais à la
5e place avec deux matches en moins de
bonne augure pour la suite du
championnat top 5 ou est ce qu'il serait
qu'il serait vraiment très très bien
pour un jeu de groupe ça serait
quatrième place qu'elle sera peut-être
qualificative donc on va essayer de
l'accrocher prochain match pour le rc
60,18 ce dimanche 13 février à 15 heures
face les voisins chevreuse un derby
important avec deux équipes figurant
dans le top 5 du classement